Colten got super shirtless the ladies
already got super dramatic they didn't
turn into a pumpkin
and we got a super three-hour premiere
this is insane it's time for roses and
rose hey hi you guys i'm lauren zima
here to recap the bachelor colton
underwood season premiere and i missed
you so much
okay we are back back back and I said
back three times because we got a
three-hour bachelor premiere didn't we
what did you think of it let me know did
we like the live premiere did we not so
I liked the premiere because here's the
thing I like something different the
show's been on for 23 seasons let's try
something different switch it up blow
bit and we got to meet some fabulous new
characters you know like that sandy or
Shelley or Sammy or whatever her name
was and that red hat over at that watch
party in Utah my heart is been I am
supposed to be mrs. bad seem at
Bennigan's and she just loved him and
done with it have to be uh-oh my voice
cracked I'm so sorry I'm very tired I
had the Golden Globes just Sunday night
and then the bachelor premiere Monday
night so who I've had about three hours
of sleep that's why my pony is so
snatched atop my head because it's
pulling it's pulling my eyes up to make
them look open and awake trick of the
trade
very nice leaf right now I just fell
asleep for a second anyway what's he
thinking as all these girls are showing
up I think he's thinking know to you
know to you know to you know to you know
to because the show was all about watch
parties and because Colton is wait for
it a virgin I thought that for roses in
Rose days first episode I would keep in
line with Coldman for my little drinking
party drink some virgin drinks now I had
to keep them like Rose a you know in the
pink theme so what about
a guava goddess kombucha or a rows of
borderline rose a rose bliss come boots
show we could do that or we have this
organic energy drink that seems like in
the vein of coltan you know just a
sparkling water a Lacroix berry flavored
who doesn't love Lacroix who doesn't
love to Sparkle these girls sparkled a
lot of night when didn't think and then
there's this a pink lemonade with
vitamins because we got to keep our
nutrients stuff for these three hours
you know what I mean and then very last
but not least I had an Italian soda a
pink soda and Italian soda because of
all the women who spoke all those
different languages tonight I don't know
a lot of Mandarin I'll teach you more
inside I felt really inadequate I only
know English and and just the most minor
amount of French that remains in my
brain from taking it for about 15 years
blue bibliothèque I speak much too
anyway I'm just kidding of course
haha Colton
don't be silly don't be ridiculous drugs
drugs drugs we've got a lot to drink you
everyone so fill your glass with me and
look at this new low wineglass I gots
got an owl on it's a Christmas gift from
a co-worker my name is Lauren anyway so
we are gonna play some drinking games
tonight but everyone please drink
responsibly as always Mike situated so
tired
we started off with Colton vigorously
showering drink every time we see Colton
shirtless tonight because wow wow wow
and I have to say I'm okay with it I'm
here for it did you like all of the
Colton's shirtless moments here's why
I'm here for it because on re-season I'm
he's having a big baby and getting
married now I've been I'm naming him
Mari on re-season
he I think was shirtless once and we
never got a showering scene and he said
it was because he didn't have time to
get I think in physical or I'd heard it
was because he didn't have time to get
like physical shape for the bachelor cuz
he got such late notice
so Colton's having to double up on his
shirtless time he's having to make up
for lost shirtless time for the fans and
Colton is doing the Lord's work and
thank you for your service
Colton is about to take the first steps
Chris Harrison starts the show drink
every time there's a bachelor viewing
party we are in Dallas Texas with
Kaitlyn and Jojo at Chris Harrison's
restaurants team theory brewing Chris
Harrison's mom also there we are in Park
City Utah with Ashley and Jared and
later Becca and Garrett and Ben and
sandy Shelley semi Sandra and the Red
Hat we are in Lansing Michigan with
Blake and Jason and Jason is really
taking this hosting thing seriously by
yelling this place is freaking Panda and
Blake is saying he's having a blast a
blast a black bear having a blast
don't drink every time Blake said blast
we're havin a blast and we are in LA
with Chris Harrison and with crystal and
goose in an outdoor hot tub and I have
to drink in just Cheers to these people
in LA because it is cold here and they
are almost naked in the outdoors Cheers
we have to drink for all the parties
partay anyway okay then
you know sprinkle throughout this live
event we are going to get the episode
how are you and we meet Hannah B from
Alabama and drink every time you're a
little bit confused about what Hannah B
is saying now I like her but she called
herself the hot mess Express why she
doesn't seem that hot mess Express C she
seems like ever stuck together the hot
mess Express and I'm the conductor she
seems cool then she says to have only
kiss for guys that word my boyfriend
what does that mean are we justifying
like I've only kissed four guys that
were my boy what about all the ones that
weren't your boyfriends you just
forgetting about those guys whatever
here's to Hannah
Colton I hope you're ready for Alvin
Mahina because Alabama Hanna is ready
three we're gonna get some pageant drama
she is not the only pageant queen in
this kingdom okay we're gonna see that
later my name is Katie I'm 26 years old
and we got Katie from California she
called herself a dancer with his her
best dance moves I love dancing did he
try acting Katie I don't know it wasn't
great Heather who is 22 has never been
kissed never kissed anyone not feeling
not my opening typically she loves the
beach to drink every time somebody on
the show Heather Cassie they just love
the beach from California we have the
most women are from California than any
other state this season so if you don't
like the beach you know get a California
why here
hi my name is Anya Khe I'm 24 years old
and then this girl oh god I'm not gonna
say her name right because I can't
remember it but drink for every letter
in her name my full name
and the thing that they put down here
more dancing and working out montages
with her and I don't know why I don't
know why I don't think that she was like
a personal trainer I don't know why we
were seeing that but her parents said
that they have been married for years
and they only dated for two weeks do we
so wow that would be the nicest hometown
ever
no skepticism from them about the
process if I was the person I Coleman
gave his virginity to I would definitely
bring out all the truth drink every time
that we get a sexual joke on tonight's
premiere all the truth I don't even know
if that's a joke it's just a sexual
comment just during first sexual comment
he's a very gentle man
I have to call out kirpa the dental
hygienist and just call out and pour one
out for her patient because for her
intro package Cooper was trying to speak
to her patient about going on the show
I'm gonna go on The Bachelor oh and
Colton
oh my god I hate when my dentist tries
to talk to me while they're cleaning my
mouth your hand is in my mouth I can't
speak to you I'm barely surviving in
this moment I'm just trying to hold on
to Who I am while you're shaming me for
not flossing and know I don't really
floss that much and I know that that's
disgusting but I don't have any cavities
and I think that a lot of the time your
dental hygiene is largely based on just
your genetics at least that's what I
tell myself
hi I'm Debbie Burnett Demi Demi Demi and
Debbie Burnett she said she's never had
a serious relationship and still lives
at home well she is 23 I don't know and
then she says my dad always had the
proper environment for us and so we've
always been with him and I'm wondering
what that means and then she says that
her mother is in federal prison for
embezzlement
that's a conversation starter that's a
limo entrance you know what I mean just
walk out and say that she puts her mom
on speakerphone hello package from the
prison and her mom says she's getting
out the 25th of what month what month is
she out now is she got one of the
viewing parties drink to her mom for
being on on that phone call on reality
TV from federal prison cheers to her
honestly feel like you got to try out
all the cupcakes first to know what you
really want I'm the damn confetti cake
she makes another sexual comment she
says that Colton needs to try all the
cupcakes first to know what he really
wants and that she's the confetti cake I
do like funfetti cake
okay so then we're actually gonna talk
about Colden and first we get shirtless
Colton with like some sexy 80s music and
it's really sexy and it's like Colton
actually showering and maybe that's an
outdoor shower or someone just like
pouring a bucket of water on his head
and I'll ticket he's got to make up for
lost time and you know then we see
Coleman working out like drink every
time we see someone working out in this
episode because there's so many workouts
and it didn't make me feel bad about
myself and then the showering takes a
turn no it's a softer more pensive
shower and he's thinking in the shower
he's really scrubbing he's scrubbing
away the past and he's cleansing himself
and he's moving into the future and the
music has become orchestral and yes
Colton found love but things got dirty
and now he's here to clean himself up
[Applause]
why does mr. Ivanoff anyway I grew up in
a pretty conservative environment I was
at a Christian school and then we hear
golden get into his past which I am so
excited about tell me if this episode
you guys we've talked about this so much
and Colton acknowledged it in this
episode that yes of course he had some
people who didn't want him to be the
bachelor but did this episode convince
you if you weren't convinced already
even though I've tried to convince you
that Colton will be a good bachelor I'm
saying that because I loved when he
opened up about look he was kind of a
chubby your kid he had some issues with
that he didn't like have girlfriends
growing up he went to a Christian school
he had you know kind of an intense
upbringing where he was super focused on
football and he's got a lot of stuff to
work through
you know he's worked through some of it
more to work through that's what makes
me excited for this season I want some
real emotional grounding in real issues
[Music]
I mean I think a ring that looks pretty
good on this fingers we get into the
limo entrances and this mean we wonder
what would your limo entrance be
everybody I want to know because it's
hard to do something that hasn't been
done before but are you gonna be the
girl who walks up and she's talking
about her dress so she's like thank you
banana yellow thank you banana
it's looks like work funded about
address banana yellow I don't know and
why are you buying addresses banana
yellow I don't think I would it be like
sunshine banana yellow Sun another
sexual comment I know what my entrance
would be by the way just just bottles of
Rosa I'm walking you know what I'm
walking and carrying a case of mine
that's what I have and then I'm like
let's play a drinking game I'm really
good to know each other I know one girl
was like paint shoes with him I thought
we could draw on them together make
little bachelor shoes and you know one
girl like had the piays I probably make
her like a her own theme park when she
did a piggyback ride with Colton where's
the pony thank you please just play
drinking game or something oh these
girls are getting a little ridiculous
just have a teen conversation okay with
a glass of wine it's a date you have a
date all righty then the girl who came
in in the banana yellow dress said quote
I have not dated a virgin since I was 12
[Music]
okay and I keep saying the girl in the
woman in the gal and I'll be honest guys
it's only because I don't know this is
the only one I picked up on was brie
with the fake Australian accent because
we kept saying gree over and over again
and then she showed up at the live show
but like I don't do you know their names
yet tell me if you know any of their
names yet and if you do whose names do
you know at this point cuz I don't know
any of them I keep going to the ABC web
site to Lego I do cross-referencing okay
Tasi makes her entrance with butterflies
and I was so nervous because she had
this box in her hand and I was like
please God don't let them open the box
and the butterflies have died you know
and then I was like taking a bird box on
Netflix if you guys watch bird box
sometimes I go off on these side
tangents and trust me I have a lot to
say about the fact that a star is born
didn't win more awards at the Golden
Globes it was very devastating to me how
could Lady Gaga not win Best Actress how
Bradley Cooper not win Best Actor and
how could
Bradley Cooper not win Best Director at
least either Best Actor or Best Director
at the end of the day to know invest
motion picture of the year seriously was
a cultural moment a box-office hit and
incredibly well reviewed film with an
incredible original motion picture sound
check the first one it's kind of a
decade for that level of a soundtrack to
make that level of impact on the
population and it didn't win more people
to vote we can believe it Hey what I
just wanna take another look at you
sober box I love huh I don't know if I
love but I like and I was afraid
something decide to leave the room and
it was a little bit scary and I'm really
obsessed with it and I can't stop saying
lines from it I don't want to spoil
anything but please let me know your
thoughts on bird box side track anyway
that was the butterfly box and I was
just glad the butterflies weren't dead
and I want to point out something
important bachelor nation did you notice
that Colton picked up one of those
butterflies and put it in his jacket
pocket hmm
I think Colton likes Cassie I think
that's telling you may remember a
Vanessa Grimaldi and Nick when they went
on that gravity dates they had little
like rubber bracelets or something from
it and Nick kept one of those all season
hmm and the picking they're not together
now but I'm just saying it's these get
that little token and I think that's
indicative
you guys have women who you felt like
holding really liked on my one spoiler
alert I mean you've already watched it
but Hannah gee got the first rose and
I'm going out of order now but who do
you think who did Colton like Hannah
obviously first impression rose I think
he likes Cassie I don't remember the
other ones names I think he would like
Hannah be the Alabama gal Hannah from
Alabama those only ones sticking out to
me right now let me know what you think
and I'm ready to eat mom is ready to eat
we had more sexual jokes a woman who
talked about eating a peach in the Train
let's try it but I think I just took
your vCard woman who made a vCard joke I
don't know I'm doing this I should be
drinking gotta play my own game what was
your favorite sexual comments of the
night did you have one or what was your
least favorite which one went on a lot I
will say what's interesting to me is I
think that women are able to get away
with these jokes a lot more than men
would be able to think about it if a guy
was making these jokes about a lady
Katherine cut in she told me to always
love on night one when we go through
some of the famous hallmarks of the show
as if we've never seen it before
like getting upset that someone's
stealing time what did you guys think of
everyone getting so riled up about
Katherine
stealing kolten over and over again stop
complaining about this ladies that's
what I think you know how the show works
go get your time with him if you can't
get in there and have a conversation and
move Katherine out of the way fYI this
is night one you're not gonna make it
all season long I don't want to hear
these complaints I don't get it together
and if you feel like your limo entrance
was a bust again you should have watched
the show and if you feel like you didn't
know everybody was gonna be dressed up
in dresses again you should have watched
the show and speaking of dresses oh I
don't know if I've ever felt more myself
than I did tonight because here's what I
learned
the Golden Globes were Sunday night and
I wore a red dress and I worked the
Globes and then an after-party so I was
just sleep-deprived and then I got into
work to do et live at 4 a.m. we went
live to recap the Globes I went home I
slept for an hour I came back here
to do the bachelor program all the
things I love and what did I see in the
bachelor from you not one not one but
two lovely ladies wearing my dress from
the Golden Globes I've never felt more
on brand I wore the dress to cover the
globe's all the entertainment news I
loved and then I came to the office to
do the bachelor premiere my favorite
show and the women were wearing the
dress I think I was looking at that same
dress online and I almost bought it
thank God I didn't and Catherine you
know Catherine came in with those
sleeves and that dog by the way and all
I could think about was Amy Poehler and
Mean Girls there are no rules in this
house I'm not like a regular mom I'm a
cool mom that's all I had what do you
think of Catherine people already
picking her as the villain do you think
Catherine is the villain I have to say
all she was doing was taking time with
him it didn't seem that villainous to me
she was just getting in there although
it was weird to me when she said if you
don't have haters you're not doing
something right yeah that's telling
Catherine we don't have to have a date
or spy we want the haters are you done
good how are you Catherine she comes in
with her entrance gives Colton her dog
and says Colton is gonna be taking care
of her dog all season savage spy raw we
know that dogs microchip at the
microphone she's listening to and
watching coldly doing a reconnaissance
work
I don't broadcast - it came to play came
to play um what was your favorite limo
entrance of the night we also had like a
Cinderella moment one girl came in and
she Colton seemed to be giving her some
kind of sports quiz about football how
many points do you get when you scored
touchdown
Wow I'd be gone it'd be so so gone I
failed the question he asked her I want
to be my partner in crime for life and
you know drink every time there was a
proposal a bunch of random people
getting engaged we are selling love on
The Bachelor tonight yes okay one girl
said quote there George Brown even some
[ __ ] we're drowning in [ __ ] at
this point several of the women seem to
be drinking coffee because we've gotten
to that place in the night Hannah gets
the first impression rose Colton kisses
some people Hannah B and Colton have an
intimate conversation which seems good
Colton comes on to the live show I
didn't think you're gonna make it up
here we get a great tribute to Chris
Harrison and you know then we have a
season teaser because it's been three
hours of this show yes the three hour
tour of the nation for the live bachelor
premiere from viewing party to viewing
party baby that was a Gilligan's Island
reference I just made you guys get that
every - this is my dating myself I
watched it on reruns on Nick at night at
my grandmother's house while eating a
bowl of cookie dough ice cream okay
while let's be crazy let's have sex
places where people shouldn't have back
we have people saying things like let's
have sex places we where people
shouldn't have sex I couldn't get out
then we cut to the champagne popping
balloons saying when I lose my virginity
it'll be tender it'll be carrying I'll
be passionate oh my god I want to be in
love the first time I have sex I am fine
in love it here Wow
we had dangerous moments in the season
trailer get away from that cliff get
away get away from the edge there it's
too scary we had water sexual
interesting moments in the trailer we
had called running away from production
and apparently they couldn't find him
he's gone oh my god I am so excited for
this season are you guys are you guys we
even kind of had a bird bucks moment in
the trailer when Colton was wandering
through the Bloods and we don't know why
I where was his blindfold I love you all
so much I'm so excited the bachelors
back and stoked for Colton the season
after this live from here I truly am but
before we wind down roses and rose a we
have to bring in a man just as important
as the bachelor JC come on in for on the
journey with Jay Z by the way all of
these kombucha surfer JC because he's
very health conscious okay I just want
to know from you your favorite moments
of the night or a standout woman or a
woman you're ready to get rid of already
okay well the sloth moment was really
slow he didn't like that I like the dog
she's not liking me here Oh with
Catherine oh not like dog oh and what
names can I remember Cassie a speech
pathologist that sounded really great
and one of the two red dresses that oh
okay the blonde red dress had more
screen time we're here for her she's
never been kissed and of course never
had sex so she's moving right along and
a good piece for Colton I think all
right guys on the journey with JC making
solid predictions he's become a real
bachelor fan as
roses I'm gonna say over the seasons we
cannot wait to talk through this season
with you leave your questions leave your
comments your thoughts on The Bachelor
and the other Bieber box in the comments
below
tweet me DM me any time and of course
follow JC over here he's such a cutie we
love you bye
[Music]